mr.
sánchez
some people have been surprised because you have made
the leading role in a television series
as in the west wing of the white house
but in moncloa version
that is,
with many more extras
because you in 3 years
has signed 500
new advisors and positions of trust to your government
never a government confirmation
it had been so expensive,
Your Honor
I already knew you had great dates as an actor.
you have played unforgettable roles
I still remember one of them especially
like when you said never ever
I would make a pact with those very bad bildu people.
or that never ever
there would be pardons for those Catalans
so disobedient
or that never ever
would you put pablo Iglesias in government?
because with that man by his side
could not sleep peacefully at night
a very good performance mr.
sánchez
so I'm not surprised either that for next year
you want to play the lead role in another movie
robin hood's
you know the one who stole from the rich
to give it to the poor
I thought I had that role taken by Pablo Iglesias.
but now it turns out that robin hood
wants to steal the votes of we can
and that's where we're at
spain's problem is not wealth
mr.
sánchez is poverty
the problem is that we are losing middle class
the problem is that the families
cannot bear the cost of
in the basket of
purchase of school supplies
in fuels at the cost of living
and that every day there are more and more people
who realize that even though they have jobs
are poorly off or do not make ends meet
you are so calm
but europe
is at real risk of suffering a huge crisis
this winter
one that can cause a disaster
in the economies of the countries
that form the heart of the European Union
you are not aware that
if the German or British economy is slowing down
there are areas of spain
tourism dependents such as the Canary Islands
that can have a brutal impact on their economy
mr.
sánchez I will tell you today
prepare a contingency plan
for the economies of the island territories
who are highly dependent on tourism
because it will be the first thing to collapse if it occurs.
an energy crisis next winter
and next year
as all international organizations say
for 48 hours
we can't get the cold to the canaries
misery will come to us
I ask you
but I have lost hope
that you pay attention to him
canaries and canaries
I mean it
or we are not understood
or they don't give a bell pepper
I don't know what's wrong with them
what I do know,
Your Honor
is that next year
the workers of the peninsula
will have free transportation and the canaries will not
you have excluded them,
your honor
what I do know president
is that next year
canary canaries will be back in line
of the state's direct investments
to the queue in violation of the law
of the economic and fiscal regime of the Canary Islands
which is a right
what I do know is that every week
Dozens of immigrants arrive on their Canarian route
and that you,
Mr. Sanchez
is able to go to dinner with the king of morocco
and boast that this has fixed the problem.
but the dead
they are shouting at you that this is not true,
Your Honor.
what i do know mr.
sánchez
is that the palm moves
and the promised aid does not arrive
and there is no funding for a reconstruction plan
in these budgets
for the next 3 years
what I do know is that every day we have more families.
who go to food banks and cavities.
purchase basket prices rise every week
there is a spain out there
which is becoming poorer and poorer
if you want to be a real robin hood
the first thing you have to do
is that the minimum living income
reach all those in need
do at once what you have to do to get it.
half of those entitled in the Canary Islands
have not been able to access the minimum living income
and those who win it in court
you appeal it again
is not reaching half of the expected number of people
you said you would take care of the most vulnerable
and that your government
would be that of modernization and change
but today he has said again everything he has done
and re-announces
important measures
as these community boilers
that do not exist in the Canary Islands
such asr trains
like gas
do not exist and we will support
so that the rest of
of the citizens of this country have such assistance
but do politics as well
against aggression
adapted to island territories
mr.
sánchez
the sad truth
is that the only thing that has changed
is that today we are poorer than yesterday
but less than tomorrow
canary islands needs you
we have a great opportunity in these budgets
so that the Canary Islands also
may have a chance
in the coming stormy weather
thank you,
madam president